no girlfriend boyfriend Haram no you you
speak to her dad hello Mato I love your
daughter I want to marry
please from black resin I do
bodybuilding boxing calisthenics I run
out of energy chit is a natural
substance found in the Himalayas created
by centuries of grass and organisms
decomposing into a thick black goo which
makes it very potent it's like a tart
light product you just get a little bit
of this onto the spoon you can get hot
water not too hot inah so it can
disintegrate into the water also there
is some studies that show it booves
testesterone even Health respiratory
system as well buy yours now brother
sisters go to the description box in and
use my discount code unless see stronger
better more focused Muslim men you are
serving their lord and their families
and their wies and their children in
Muslim in Islam woman's rights yeah your
your your girlfriend yeah okay Islam you
know what Islam says can she drive can
of course you can drive Prophet
prophet's wife have C you know camel
yeah because no cars back then it's fine
Saudi Arabia have opinion we don't this
is not from Islam she can drive no
problem yeah but you should drive her
yeah okay in Islam in Islam when you
want to marry her no girlfriend
boyfriend Haram no you you speak to her
dad hello what's your dad name
sister hello M I love your daughter I
want to marry please and she say okay
what's your name sister uh feita fita
say Okay father speak to her fita this
man want to marry you like him yes
Father good man handsome man one day he
become a Muslim you know and you say I
want
£10,000 she say I want £10,000 I have I
do have to pay yes this is minimum
brother what do you think this is my
wife she give me installment plan I pay
every month she very good yes uh no very
expensive she's worth every penny Okay
if she's watching this uh yes anyways
get very nice food cakes anything anyway
now number one you speak to the dad
number two she asked for gold watch car
what she want up to you up to her what
she want number two you have to do
wedding wedding wima wedding you tell
everybody this is my wife everybody know
you happy man she happy yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you have to do wedding when you
marry you pay for the rent you know rent
yeah now you're scared I can see you're
very scared yes you pay for the rent you
pay for the shopping you pay for
electric gas bill now Russia problem
electric prices gas we finished yes yes
so she needs some kind of money for
shopping whatever you can give1 a
month00 a month this is her right this
is all on your shoulder the right of
woman this is one thing so this is your
rights her rights on you so you have to
speak speak to the dad wedding M pay pay
pay pay finish we finished yes sad but
this is right why and also if you
walking down the road somebody come
knife yeah yeah she fight or you fight I
fight ah good you finished now J yeah so
now you are maintainer and protector you
like bodyguard full-time bodyguard but
also she you are the head of the house
in Christianity it says uh Christ is the
head of the church and you are the head
of something like this even in the Bible
she have to listen to you but not you
don't become bad good you say for
example you know there's one leader in
the house not two women they like a
leader somebody Stronger Yeah so you are
the leader of the house so you make
final decisions yeah if you tell her you
know I don't want you to have bad
friends she have to listen to you yeah
so these things woman's rights for
example she she doesn't have to take
your surname what's your surname h no no
no I love Italian
no yes she your surname she doesn't have
to take usually she have to take your
surname yes Islam no she doesn't take
your surname one moment this thing in
Islam so is it still working you know
cuz you know that now the world is
changing the RO of
the sorry no what sorry sorry I don't
speak Arabic second yeah so is it
working it look let me tell you why it
would work in today's time the roles of
genders have been you know mixed why
because now feminism come feminism come
and say to the woman yeah you go work I
know we have to smash feminism me I
smash feminism every day so how how how
they Muslim cope with feminism we smash
intellectually now why because feminism
say to a woman you are just like a man
no she is psychologically mentally
physically emotionally she is different
she needs she needs protecting she needs
loving yes so feminism say no you go
work to your 30 30 years old woman less
likely to conceive have a baby become
hard so Islam says no women have a role
man have a role they are not the same
they are different there's something she
needs you have to give some things you
need so Islam deals with real ity
feminism is a dream you know dream you
sleep you wake up oh feminism is a dream
so Islam give a solution to whole
mankind number one with God relationship
with God to relationship with us
relationship with your wife and your
Society Islam wants this because women
have certain rights but today's society
they make a Woman They think the sexual
Liber Liberation they think this give
rights to women no because men are happy
now they have what they want no marriage
have sex have this have that and no
marriage this is not good for a woman
for a woman it is better that she has
certain things you like me you want to
marry me okay speak to my dad Mah
wedding IM man he run away he say no I
don't want this that's why Islam has
these things to protect women otherwise
now men are lucky go sleep around they
don't want it you know men don't get
married anymore why you get married you
get everything you get in a marriage why
is you going to why would I pay £10,000
do a wedding I get yeah I understand I
understand you understand